bienvenue à cannes on vous emmène dans
les coulisses du festival strass
paillettes soirée à cannes de nombreux
professionnels viennent surtout faire du
business et des rencontres c'est le cas
de l'ubs beau quand le directeur du ciné
c est à elancourt le marché du film de
cannes est l'un des événements les plus
importants de l'industrie
cinématographique avec plus de dix mille
professionnels ici des producteurs des
distributeurs des vendeurs et des
programmateurs de festivals et que tes
films on trouve de tout à cannes le
meilleur comme le pire du plus classique
au plus surprenant le marché du film
c'est vraiment pour le distributeur en
fait les producteurs les distributeurs
ils vendent les films à l'international
et c'était ça mais il projette aussi des
films
donc on a accédé fois de temps en temps
on peut réussir à choper si je puis dire
une invitation pour aller voir un film
ou deux mais c'est quand même assez rare
au marché de films ya tout il ya un peu
de tout et n'importe quoi enfin ça c'est
normal il ya tous les gens du gore la
série z la série b et cetera par contre
dans les sélections officielles on va
dire que ce soit quinzaine acide enfin
etc je vais pas toutes les citer il ya
quand même plutôt du bon voire du très
très bon on voit le un maximum de films
c'est vachement important pour nous
parce qu'on a exploitants parce qu'on a
assez peu le temps de voir les films en
amont dans l'année parce qu on est tout
le temps en train de courir après la la
mécanique si je puis dire
les projections de presse à paris en a
quelques unes on arrive à y aller mais
pas toujours c'est le bloc une demi
journée voire une journée
on n'a pas toujours le temps donc cannes
c'est vraiment loverdos si je puis dire
de deux films on les enchaîne on les
voit et on l'est on prend des notes
et ensuite quand on les a aimés on les
programme et on les défend c'est ça qui
est important
cannes c'est également une chance pour
les plus jeunes de se faire un nom dans
le métier tu es où le roi y est un
ancien élève des trois yes l'institut
international de l'image et du son de
trappes il n'a que 21 ans et déjà de
nombreux projets en tête cette année il
est venu à cannes pour travailler aux
côtés d'une attachée de presse
mais légalement emmené avec lui son
dernier court-métrage triangle une
histoire d'amour pourquoi ce film
ça va partir d'un constat très simple
c'est mon film de fin d'études donc il
fallait que je livre 1
une idée un film à telle date je savais
qu'on allait tourner c'est en troisième
année notre film de fin d'études et j'ai
cherché des idées et oui en fait
finalement je me suis rabattu fin a
battu pascal bon mot mais je me suis dit
j'ai parlé des expériences personnelles
en fait et à partir de là ce qui était
rigolo c'était de prendre quelque chose
que j'avais plus ou moins vécu être un
joujou avec et puis d'en faire un film
et puis changer tous les éléments du
tour de départ mais voilà quelques bars
y avait peut-être aussi envie de parler
de moi et et c'est peut-être le plus
simple aussi parler de ce qu'on connaît
pour s'amuser avec
oui
moi depuis depuis tout petit je regarde
le festival avec avec mes parents à la
télé c'était un peu un rêve de gosse et
et c'est vrai que à la télé ya tout le
côté paillettes et du côté comme ça et
en fait on se rend compte que quand on
est là les gens ne font que parler de
cinéma et c'est un côté beaucoup plus je
sais pas comment dire peut-être un peu
familial mais il ya un vrai côté on est
tous ensemble je sais pas combien on s
pour le festival mais c'est énorme on
est tous avec l'outil d'accréditation
c'est tout sans se reconnaît dans la rue
on sait qu'on fait partie du festival
est en fait je trouve que mon moi
j'avais fait des belles rencontres et on
discute avec plein de gens et en fait on
parle que de signer au mondial ce que tu
as vu tel film at-elle sélection à
celui-là il est super as tu l'as vu un
machin on discute en fait on sait
chanter place aussi pour essayer d'aller
au célèbre fin à notre démarche mais
juste comme ça c'est de la bidouille et
c'est vraiment dix jours dans une bulle
ciné vous pourrait se passer un truc à
paris qu on ne serait même pas c'est ça
c'est ça la magie et on se quitte avec
une autre star du jour le coiffeur
franck provost c'est dans les yvelines à
saint germes en les kilos vers son
premier salon en 1975 et chaque année à
cannes avec ses équipes de coiffure et
de maquilleurs et le sublime les stars
qui montent les marches pour un résultat
souvent en plein de magie et de glamour
un réel plaisir de devenir mais
effectivement on est là déjà pour
travailler et c'est pas vraiment
travaille beaucoup et quand je savais
les coiffeurs on va coiffer d'une de on
est basé nous au martinez mais on va se
déplace dans tous les hôtels et ça veut
dire que des coiffeurs sans arrêt ils
font la navette sur la croisette avec
leurs valises et tout et je peux vous
garantir que les valises ça pèse parce
que on
transportent les lacs les produits les
les épingles et tout donc quand ils ont
fait ça arrive qu'on commence des
journées à 8 heures le matin pour des
photos et souvent à 23 heures ça se
termine donc c'est un vrai vrai
challenge mais en même temps il ya une
espèce de de dynamisme de d'euphorie de
la part de tout le monde donc finalement
on oublie la fatigue quoi parce que ici
à il se passe quelque chose c'est
magique quoi ya pas de se trouve pas
d'autres mots que pour qualifier les
cannes cannes c'est magique 4,78 c'est
tout pour aujourd'hui et n'oubliez pas
comme le dit jean luc godard la
télévision fabrique de l'oublier le
cinéma fabrique des souvenirs